- I'm a PhD in molecular
biology turned mom,
obsessed with feeding my kids nutritious,
flavorful, fun food.
Today, I'm gonna show you three easy ways
you can meal-prep for your picky eater.
Exposing kids to a wide variety of foods
in different ways is really important.
Buy foods you yourself
are super excited about.
Shopping with your kids,
whether at the grocery store,
the farmers market, such
a great way to give them
a sense of control.
And I gotta always have on
hand my Happy Family Organics
fruit and veggie pouches.
Great for when in a pinch,
adding new nutrition
and flavors to existing
foods that my kids love.
Which kid doesn't love pancakes.
Today, we're gonna make these oat, banana,
cinnamon pancakes, with the
Happy Family Organics pouch
with sweet potato,
pumpkin, pear, and banana.
We're gonna start with a cup of oats.
Get your kids to help you crack the eggs.
Great way to get them
involved in the kitchen.
The goal here is not to try to be sneaky
with the fruits and veggies.
Talk to your kids about what you've put
in the pancake batter,
why it's exciting today.
That's the texture that we like.
It's smooth, but it still has
a little bit of a bite to it.
So, when you start to see
tiny bubbles on the top,
you know that it's time to flip.
There we go!
Ooh, look at the color on that!
I love to serve these
pancakes with nature's candy,
also known as fresh fruit.
A great way to get picky eaters
to eat a wide variety of foods,
is to take one food that they love,
to batch prep it, and then to
put it into different dishes.
And we're gonna do exactly that,
with these five spice,
veggie-loaded meatballs.
These meatballs are
great for picky eaters,
because they are veggie-loaded.
They have flavor in the form
of five spice, the onion,
the ginger, so you're
keeping their palates awake.
We're gonna add in the red onion.
And you really just wanna soften this.
You don't want to overcook it,
'cause it will burn quickly.
There is nothing that makes me happier
than spending time in the
kitchen, whipping something up,
and having my kids enjoy it.
It is the most exhilarating
moment for me in mom life.
While the meatballs are in the oven,
we are gonna make our glaze.
All we're gonna do is mix
soy sauce and orange juice.
These meatballs have
become a staple on the menu
for every birthday party, play date,
and anytime my kids are going
through a picky eating phase.
And with this set of
meatballs, you can make three
different dishes: egg
frittata muffins, quesadillas,
and a noodle soup.
The Happy Family Organics pouches
were a real lifesaver for
me when my son was a toddler
and only wanted purees.
Happy Family Organics
has this really valuable,
live-chat feature on their website,
where parents who are overwhelmed
with all this conflicting information
about what to feed and
not feed their kids,
can go for genuine advice.
Parenting is no joke.
Just embrace the chaos,
embrace the ups and downs,
and just realize that
we're all in this together.
And it is one of the most
rewarding experiences
we will ever have.